are you ready because I am what if I
said no
it will kill
the Executioner sword
[Music]
the Executioner sword performed its
bloody work in 16th century Central
Europe unlike combat swords this lethal
blade features a straight double-edged
cutting blade with a blunt tip perfect
for swiftly chopping off the heads of
criminals this deadly weapon was used on
many aristocratic felons rather than the
ax since it allowed the victim to meet
his end in a dignified kneeling position
rather than face down with his head on
the Block while The Executioner's sword
fell out of use in the early 18th
century this gruesome sword is still
wielded in the 2019 video game mordhaus
basements welcome to the Keel test
the Executioner sword that word alone
just gives you visions of decapitated
heads so to find out what kind of lethal
damage your executioner sword can do
I'll deliver some while lethal blows on
this ballistics dummy
Nathan is it time it's time have fun
[Music]
crap
just a little off the top
[Laughter]
all right Ethan first stop this is a
heavy Beast it is so forward heavy that
you need two hats to control that now
your handle construction is smooth I'll
give you that but it also feels a little
bit rounded over here where it actually
gives me much more control sideways than
it does this way but overall your
weapons sir filled with Keel awesome
all right Gunner your turrets are you
ready absolutely let's do this
[Music]
all right Gunners talk about your
executioner sword over here your blade
right here has a finer grind so it makes
it a little bit lighter and the edge
that you have here when it came to that
skull just glided into that overall sir
your Executioner's sword it will kill
thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the skull and bone chop
now to test the overall construction of
your blades as well as how they feel
while they're being used I'll be
chopping into these skulls and that
nasty giraffe bone
Nathan you're up are you ready yes sir
have fun
[Music]
yeah
I'll be drafted
all right Nathan so right off man this
thing is heavy but once you get it
moving it's going but controlling it's
tough having said that your Edge hello
beautifully it's still just as sharp as
when I started which is pretty darn
sharp so good job on that thanks I like
sharp things
ready
what if I said no I'd say you don't
watch this so much do you exactly
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right so gonna write off lighter
blade easier to control a lot of that
has to do with the fact you've got more
handle here
now your blade it's got some compacting
on the edges but I wouldn't run my
finger down this Edge it's still for
Lonnie sharp nicely done thank you sir
all right blade Smiths this is the
sharpness test the Jackfruit and water
jug slice
Ethan you're up first you ready yes sir
have fun all right let's do this
[Music]
still Sharp
all right Nathan as far as the downward
chop it's a very clean cut easy no
resistance whatsoever now when I was
cutting as soon as I met the resistance
of the water it kind of rolled on my
hand
but anything that it did have contact
with it was able to cut overall sir your
weapon it will cut thank you
all right go to your turn so you ready
yes sir I am let's do this
foreign
[Music]
ER the handle construction you have here
is wide and oh void enough to where when
I hold on to it I can really tell where
the edge is and it's much easier to
control a blade like this in the slice
you can see that cuts nicely overall sir
your weapon will cut thank you
well boys Miss only one of you can leave
here with the title of Fortune fire
champion and get that check for ten
thousand dollars now the judges
discussed your blades and they made a
final decision
today's Fortune fire Champion is
Gunner congratulations now Nathan you
fought hard man but unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut I'm gonna have
to ask you to please step off the forge
floor thank you very much
congratulations
well I'm gonna have to find a different
way to take my wife to go see Bigfoot
but we're still gonna go
well Gunner that makes you the fortune
fire Champion you just got yourself a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations thank you appreciate it
guys
[Applause]
I just won forged in fire feeling good
well I mean I've never thought I would
make it this far from day one I don't
necessarily think that I'm a better
Smith than any of these other guys that
just worked out in my favor today as far
as the money uh after football season
ends my wife and I will probably take a
long weekend somewhere
foreign
[Music]
rising to popularity in Italy during the
16th and 17th centuries the skiavona
became the trusted weapon for
Mercenaries recruited to guard the
Venetian head of state the swords Long
Blade included multiple Fullers to
lighten its weight while its straight
double edged made it conducive for
deadly thrusters and cuts the most
eye-catching feature of this blade was
its basket Hilt with multiple pieces of
Steel that intertwined to protect the
hand from brutal slashes it's attractive
yet deadly qualities are why the
skiavona can still be found today in
popular games such as Assassin's Creed
alright bladesmiths as you can see I'm
still recovering from an injury so to be
my arm today and have the pleasure of
testing your weapon I'd like to bring
back one of my favorite students my
brother RJ markaida
foreign
the one issue I have about your handle
right here it did cause some issues by
rubbing against the thumb right there
but more importantly it has a sharp
blade for slashing and thrusting it will
kill
cool
Jeff you ready let's do this
[Music]
oh
one right here okay all right Jeff a
little bit on the inside of your basket
Hilt right there it did dig in into his
knuckles
but overall if we're talking about a
killing blade here with good balance and
the kind of Destruction it did it will
kill
your job
all right blade Smiths next stop is a
strength test Ben
to test your shabona's basket and blade
I'm gonna punch into these terracotta
parts and then chop into these virtual
orgs and remember it's not what happens
to the valves or the wood it's what
happens to your blade
you're up first you ready my shiovanna
is definitely ready
foreign
once I started chopping into that log it
was just going the whole time there is a
tiny little deformation right there it's
pretty narrow
you can hear it you know
all in all it's sharp and it's a good
Chopper nicely done yeah
all right Jeff you're up you ready let's
do this
well Jeff
this is a heck of a chopper it's got a
lot of forward weight it's a little bit
on the heavy side but not too much in
general and in total it held up very
well nice job thank you
all right gentlemen this is our
sharpness test a rope and sandbag slash
what I'll do to test the edges of your
blade is slice the Rope releasing the
sandbag then cut the bag what we want to
see are good clean cuts through the rope
and clean cuts through the bag Brad
you're up first you ready ready
oh
okay Brett on the cuts pass through the
rope with no problem this blade has a
beautiful Edge a fine cutter excellent
well done thank you
Jeff you ready let's get it on all right
let's do this
I think right now we're almost dead even
couldn't be any closer
all right Jeff what I like about your
blade is it's look this industrial look
it's cool it didn't slice all the way
through the bag but it cuts very cleanly
nicely done thank you
Brad Jeff you were both extraordinary
weaponsmiths but there can only be one
for it to fire champion
Jeff congratulations you are a newest
Fortune fire Champion Brad unfortunately
your weapon did not make the cut Brad
this is probably the most difficult Hilt
design we have sent any of our Smiths
home to do and you both did a really
nice job and we had to look at the
finest of details and that that rolled
Edge you took in the strength test
that's why we've got to send you home
Brad please surrender your weapon
I did the best that I could and I put
every single bit of effort into my blade
and Jeff I hope we become friends
forever I definitely have a lot to learn
from you
and I'm just so close to being the
champion
Jeff you are the new forged and fire
champion and will be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars how do you feel
my heart's pounding out of my chest this
is what I came here to do please present
your weapon to the judges I feel
freaking awesome this is everything this
is what I wanted
it's perfect
I heard Brendan might have called me
Magic Mike but I'll tell you what the
magic who's floating baby the magic is
floating
the headhunter's ax
the Headhunter ax is both a tool and a
weapon of the native igora tribe who
hailed from the mountains of the
Philippines featuring a sharp Spike on
one side that is used to pierce Shields
and armor it also contained a wide
lethal ax head on the other side
designed to swiftly decapitate enemies
in the heat of battle an intimidating
weapon tribes would display the heads of
their victims to strike fear into their
enemies the legacy of this deadly act
lives on today and can be seen in the
video game State of Decay breakdown
blazeness welcome to the Keel test
the igorot Headhunters ax a weapon that
I've always fantasized about because
it's very close to my Filipino Heritage
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your headhunter's ex will do I will take
your weapon and deliver some lethal
blows on this ballistics dummy Jordan
are you ready because I am so let's do
this
right now I'm pretty intimidated if that
Spike hits the backbone or the skull or
anything like that I think could snap
right off
all right
all right Jordan let's talk about your
Headhunters ax here your edges here are
very sharp with every strike it dug in
very deep into this ballistics dummy the
spike you have here even digging into
the skull did not bend it feels good in
the hand and more importantly sir
heal thank you
all right Jesse you're up next are you
ready I'm ready let's do this
I'm feeling nervous I'm worried about my
ax head flying off the socket because
those bones are dense you know going
into a human skull is not an easy task
s
foreign
all right Jesse let's talk about your
headhunter's ax over here first up the
handle construction somebody did some
research in some Polynesian tattoos
there looks good and it feels good in
the hand your edges here penetrated very
deep into this ballistics dummy now your
Spike here not only did it penetrate the
skull but it also cut it and it stayed
true overall sir your headhunter's ex
little Keel thanks Doug
all right gentlemen Welcome to our
strength test the bamboo and skull chop
now you get two totally different
materials here you got the springy
bamboo that likes to bounce things back
in the skulls at like the break edges so
we're going to test both ends and the
overall construction of your Headhunters
axes during your smiles you're up first
how about that yes sir okay let's do it
ah
[Music]
Jordan nice job take a breath now
everything held up nicely
everything's tight doesn't look like
anything moved your edges are still
sharp I mean the fact that you made this
thing light tough and in Damascus in
three days that's a heck of a feat good
job thank you
all right Jesse how do you feel after
seeing that not good not good it'll be
fine okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
last one man
all right Jesse on the plus side
it felt great in the hand
and your edges held up just fine
but just all the shock wave from The
Forest of those strikes split the handle
almost in half so definitely not going
to be able to continue testing with this
weapon
foreign
Jesse we absolutely hate to see that
happen phenomenal job on your blade
itself but unfortunately you had a
catastrophic failure when your handle
broke and for that reason we can no
longer continue testing your weapon I'm
gonna have to ask you to please leave
the forge
broken seeing something that I put so
much work into would be broke but I came
onto this competition just to prove that
I can compete with some of the best
blade Smiths out there and I know I've
already accomplished that so I still
feel like I'm going home a winner
well Jordan you survived the test your
blade came out on top so congratulations
you are the forge and fire champion and
there's a ten thousand dollar check
waiting for you outside that door very
well done
I just won fours and fire I don't really
know what to say right now Sasquatch is
kind of my mascot and so I feel like
that's a Sasquatch worthy ax
a falcon
hahaha yeah one of the most popular
weapons during the Middle Ages the
falshin was a commoner sword that found
widespread use both on and off European
battlefields a thick and heavy sword
falcian's featured either a straight or
slightly curved blade with a single
sharp edge making it well suited for the
vicious Close Quarters combat of
medieval Wars eventually this Broad and
deadly hacking weapon transitioned from
a combat sidearm to a hunting sword like
other historic European weapons of its
time although the falshin disappeared
from battlefields and hunting grounds
its Legacy virtually lives on in video
games like Warhammer vermintide 2 and
Dark Souls 3.
all right bladesmiths this is the Keel
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do according to its
historic design I will try to cut this
big carcass in half when you're up first
you ready for this absolutely
one and done well now all right Wayne
your file Sean is beautiful it is sharp
we've cut through the spine and all the
way through the pig it's a little bit
heavier for one-handed weapon but it is
well balanced overall sir it will kill
awesome
all right Mark your turn sir are you
ready let's give it a shot
all right Mark's talk about your file
Sean here it's a nice lighter blade your
edges are sharp enough to cut through
spine but the problem I have here is
your guard
your edges here are not rounded they dig
in right here where the thumb is but
your blade sir it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
I'll be attacking our armored dummy here
this test is not about what your swords
do to that armor it's about what that
armor does to your swords Wayne you're
up you ready
let's do it
[Music]
oh cool
first off Wayne your Edge has taken some
small chips some small rolls but it's
very very minor damage there's still a
sharp edge here all in all it held up
beautifully all right thank you
so Mark I gotta ask what's with the
shirt I got married in this shirt
actually uh it's you know it's my Formal
Wear all right while you're ready for
the test I am okay
[Music]
all right
thank you
not bad
all right so first off the blade is
still solid you did get some minor
rolling but the blade still has an edge
down here is the problem your guard
these edges are not just Square they're
sharp
but the blade held up good job thank you
foreign
now it's time to find out if there's any
sharpness left to your weapons to test
the edge of your weapon let's cut
through this Gauntlet of sandbags
wait you're first you ready for this oh
yeah
[Music]
all right Wayne your weapon is sharp on
every swing it cuts and slashes nicely
and most importantly aside from being
smurfed
it looks awesome
all right Mark it's your turn you ready
I am let's have fun
[Music]
[Music]
all right Mark and she can see on both
these bags it cut deeply on the second
bag on the swing back over there it must
have hit a dull spot it did Rip parts of
the bag but it didn't cut all the way in
but overall it is sharp and it will cut
thank you
Wayne Mark was a tight decision
Wayne congratulations you're the forged
and fire Champion Mark unfortunately
your blade didn't make the cut please
surrender your weapon and leave the
Forge from start to finish this whole
thing was a learning process for me and
I honestly think I have gotten years
worth of experience and feedback in just
a short time
you too this experience was
life-changing
Wayne congratulations you are one bad
ass Everlasting bladesmith and our new
forcedent fire Champion good job brother
yeah yes
please at this time present your blade
to our judges
the same thing that's led me to this
point which is just non-stop going Full
Throttle I'm just gonna keep pushing I'm
Gonna Keep weak better and better
foreign
ER
the Spy hander which means two-hander in
German was a massive sword wielded by
Swiss and German mercenary armies in the
16th century sometimes stretching over
six feet in length this by-hander was a
long sword featuring an extended grip in
Broad Garden as European armies employed
more Pikes and pole arms on the
battlefield the zyhander emerged as a
counter weapon this enormous sword was
used to break up Pike formations by
cutting spear ends and opening up holes
in Enemy Lines due to its size the Spy
hander was only wielded by the biggest
and most audacious soldiers if these
soldiers survived charges into enemy
Spears they would often be paid double
for their substantial risk the
zweihander eventually faded from the
battlefield but survives today in games
such as Dark Souls your spy handers are
big so we came to a big open space to
test them up first the sharpness test
Dave
now the survivander was known as a
weapon of intimidation to test the
sharpness of your Edge I'm going to cut
into this bundle of sugar cane twice
once with either side
Jay you're up first are you ready as I'm
ever going to be
questions
it's got a lot of weight to it but
obviously it's plenty Sharp
nicely done thank you all right Stephen
you're up are you ready can't wait Jay's
weapon did really well cutting through
the sugar canes I'm not nervous about
mine but you know I don't know if it's
going to cut better than his his cut
real strong
[Music]
it's light it's easy to wield
that guard it's almost where it's
into you when you're swinging it
you can see it cut deep and clean it
looks like the blade held it beautifully
so nice job thank you
blades bits this yander was a weapon of
War big weapon big damage I will take
your weapon and deliver killing blows on
this ballistic dummy let's see how much
damage your weapon can do
Jay up first you ready go for it let's
do this
foreign
it is a heavy weight and it's harder to
manipulate with multiple blows but on
the thrust I was able to go in one side
and all the way
on the opposite side of the dummy
yes sir will kill
thank you
Stephen you're up next you ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
that was brutal
okay Steve
the edge of your sword
is sharp enough to last weight all the
way into the ribs and on the power
strike that would disembowel
and ruin this person
it's the idea this sword will kill
good job thank you
gentlemen this is the strength test now
the zioner was often used against Pike
formations so I'm going to take yours by
handers and go against a rack of Pikes
here five times with each of your blades
see how far I can break through
Jay you're up are you ready ready
[Music]
so after two tests Stephen and uh
they're pretty neck and neck so I feel
pretty nervous because this next test
should really determine who's going to
take home the prize
thank you
wow
when you start swinging this thing it
moves things out of its way
I don't see any damage to your Edge
nicely done thank
you all right Steve you're up do it okay
foreign
obviously it's a good cutter to actually
Bend into that wood and split that right
down the middle very easy to wield
because of its lightweight but I think
we've
bent just a little bit
it's bent in two directions and there is
a crack now developing in the handle
gentlemen we've got a lot to discuss
we'll see you back at the forge I'm
concerned I had a warp in my blade so I
don't know who's going to end up with
the Wind
bladesmiths the judges have made their
final decision it's time to declare one
of you the forged and fire champion
Jay congratulations
Stephen unfortunately your sword did not
make the cut please surrender your
weapon
I'm disappointed I really wanted to win
but that's okay I love being at the
forge it's hot it's dirty you'll smell
funny but it is so rewarding
Jay congratulations you were the forest
and fire Champion good job
thank you how you feel right now oh I
feel like my heart's about to burst out
of my chest but most heaviest weapon
I've ever had to wield in this
competition very well balanced and a
powerful weapon too thank you and the
way you built your handle that that
tells me a lot about the way that you
make things the wood is fitted on and
then wrapped with leather with these
reinforcing pieces underneath that's the
proper way to construct it oh thank you
well Jay in exchange for that sword and
those socks and we'll be receiving that
check for ten thousand dollars when they
announced that I was the winner it felt
really good I had people tell me you
know you're good at what you do but I
always have this kind of self-doubt to
make it all the way to the end and be
the champion I'm so happy